[MUSIC PLAYING]
FELIPE HOFFA: Today, my
talk, the talk you chose,
is about the Google Cloud
Public Datasets Program.
You might be familiar
with Google Cloud,
you might know many
of the tools we offer.
If you don't know them, I will
show you these tools again.
My goal here is to show you
what we are doing forward
with Public Data, how do we
make it more accessible, more
usable, drive more
insights from it.
I'm Felipe Hoffa, you
can find me on Twitter.
I've been at Google
for almost six years.
I started as a
software engineer and I
became a developer advocate
around three years ago.
This shirt is from the first
time I spoke at Google I/O.
And I'm still here,
so that's cool.
So this talk is about
open data and we
want to go beyond availability.
Making data available, leaving
it somewhere is not enough.
We need the best tools to
share and work with data.
The state of the
art before, when
if you wanted to download, let's
say, the weather for last year,
you would find an FTP server,
this is a NOAA FTP server,
try to connect, try
to find files there.
This one is a 100
megabyte files with all
of the weather for 2016.
And that's nice, you can
download, access that data.
But we want more, because once
we download this file, what
do we do with it?
How do we extract insights?
Where do we install it?
Why do we even have to do this?
Especially with big datasets.
As datasets get bigger
and bigger and bigger,
it's not that easy to
download and install it
on our own computers.
And the most interesting
direction we're going now,
I'm really excited, is how do
we work with live datasets?
Let's say you need
to send millions
of messages in real time, you
want to publish in real time.
Then we will be able to help
you to do that kind of sharing.
But I'll come back
to that later.
Open data impacts
so many sectors.
It's in so many places.
It's not only saving data,
it's not only comments.
We have agriculture, art,
business, consumer, education.
I could go on and on and on.
There are so many fields that
benefit from this, including
health, definitely been able to
share terabytes of genome data
that's been used to fight cancer
and other health problems.
It's a really impactful
place to be working in.
Going back in time, I love
sharing a little bit of--
what companies built on
public data do you know.
AUDIENCE: Waze.
FELIPE HOFFA: Waze,
kind of public data.
But Google.
I like that answer
because if you go back
to 1996, when there were
a lot of search companies,
search was solved.
We know all of these, or if
you were back there, back then
searching on the
internet you had
to go through all of them trying
to find whatever you wanted,
page number 10.
It was hard, it was hard.
They were all looking at the
same data, the public web.
They were all
collecting the web,
ranking the results in
the best way possible,
and serving it from the biggest
server that they could find.
But then in 1998, Google shows
up, it looks at the same data,
it's the same web
pages, but instead
of looking only at the
content of each web page,
Google starts looking at the
relationships between them,
the page rank algorithm.
What I'm trying to
show here is that we
had a new idea, PageRank, just
with the same data collecting
the whole web and with a new
generation of technology.
The technology that
Google used was
pretty different to
what everyone else was
doing at the time.
At the time, everyone was trying
the biggest server possible.
Google had new technology ideas.
And you could do the same.
How do we empower your
ideas with more data?
How do we make--
instead of having
to collect all this data, how
can we collect it for you?
How can we share the
technology that we
have created with you to empower
whatever your next ideas are?
Because that's what
changes the world.
Google on the technology
side, we've created--
at first we published
many of the papers that
revolutionized the big data
world with the internet
as we know today.
It all started with the file
system, the Google file system
being able to store a
limited gigabytes of data.
And then MapReduce this idea
on, how do we move computing?
Instead of having
it in one computer,
orchestrating it on 1,000 of
them of cheaper computers.
And so many other papers
that on the last few years
we've been translating
that to a world where
instead of sharing paper,
we share the same technology
that we're using.
All of these papers,
you can access them now
off Google Cloud products.
You might have been
using some of them.
The last one, this
one, it's public now.
It's available now.
You can use Spanner tool.
But I'm going to focus
on other products here
that allows us to
share and analyze data.
Now, when we think
about open data,
there's a lot of different
ways data can be shared.
It's not only structured data,
CSVs, spreadsheets, et cetera.
You can also have unstructured
data, text, annotations, DNA,
images of petabytes, of
satellites, pictures, of sky,
et cetera, et cetera.
These All require
different tools.
We don't want to be
another open data portal.
Today there are
more than 500 data
portals all around the world.
This is one that was being
counted by open knowledge,
yes, a civic data.
But there are so many portals.
We don't want to
replace them, they
are all doing an amazing job.
We want to empower.
We want to help
where we can help,
where we can make
things different.
To give you an
example, Stack Exchange
has their own portal with
the stack overflows data.
So here you can
find questions, you
can find the queries
people can use.
You can run your own queries and
they let you run your queries
on their server.
And it's really cool.
It's a great place to
share, to learn, to analyze,
to understand.
It's fast, it's easy, it's cool.
But it has some limitations,
because at the end of the day,
we're using their
server that has
limitations so
they have to impose
those limitations on us too.
The max number of rows you can
output, they don't have an API,
they don't allow robots,
queries sometimes time out,
and you cannot
mix your own data.
It's their server, you
don't want to upload data
to their server.
So in cases like this,
we can really help.
We can go past
these limitations.
When you're sharing
data, too many users
would be a problem, too many
questions, too many indexes,
the ability to run
any kind of question
is one of the
things we can offer.
And especially the cost model,
because sharing one server,
sharing your own servers can
become an expensive endeavor.
With the tools I'm
going to show you,
you are able to share
data without bearing
the cost of the analysis.
With BigQuery, with
Pub/Sub, the model
here is that the person
doing the analysis
can pay for their own
analysis so it doesn't impact
your own ability to share.
So we can create
a sharing platform
to help with bigger datasets,
with streaming datasets.
We can bring
flexibility, like knowing
the access needed for
sharing, or if you
have a stream of data, help
with all of the security
and without needing
to configure anything.
You can bring your own data.
People that want to
mix public datasets
with their own private
datasets, they can do everything
in the same platform, they
can scale in a serverless way,
don't worry about
servers anymore.
You can distribute the cost
and we can also act as Google
as a data provider.
With a public dataset program,
we want to help bring in data
and cleaning the data so
it can be analyzed in time.
So this is the Google Cloud
Public Datasets Program,
what we have been working for
the last year, setting it up.
When I started working in this
role, I got a lot of datasets.
And that big
dataset that I could
find, I'd put it into BigQuery,
I shared it with people,
I shared an article.
But that was a one-man job.
Right now we have a team,
we have a formal program
that's helping do
the same, but do it
in a productionized matter,
have these datasets updated,
have everything coming together.
Some benefits from the
Public Dataset Program
are that if you contact
us, we can give you
free hosting and credits.
If you want to share data,
we can help you with that.
We can help you
setting up a pipeline
to update these
datasets every day,
every hour, when
and however we need.
And we can provide documentation
on cloud.google.com.
That's really good
for people that are
looking to work with this data.
BigQuery has a free tier, 1
terabyte of monthly querying
quota for everyone.
So if you share
data on BigQuery,
anyone can come and analyze
these datasets at no cost
up to a limit.
But then if they want to do
much more, they're able to.
We also added a Pub.
We added a whole free tier
now for many other products
and that was an announcement
that [INAUDIBLE] time.
With BigQuery and Pub/Sub,
you can distribute costs,
you can make things serverless,
you can make them open.
I'm going to show you BigQuery
and Pub/Sub in a few slides.
You just want to enable
people to combine datasets,
to bring new insights, to go
beyond analysis, to use it
with machine
learning, et cetera.
So with this, I love
jumping into demo time
because you might already
know this product,
but seeing them in use,
it's my favorite part.
Who knows BigQuery?
A lot of hands, nice.
The other half will
get to meet it, too.
BigQuery is our serverless
way of analyzing data.
It analyzes
terabytes in seconds,
you can use it just
by knowing SQL,
it scales from
bytes to petabytes.
There's nothing to
turn on, there's
no investment necessary, it's
just working all the time.
It will work with
many other tools,
with Tableau, R,
Python, [INAUDIBLE],
it has a REST API agent,
JDBC connector, [INAUDIBLE]
connector.
And the most interesting
part for me and for this talk
is being able to share
data instantly and giving
the free quota for everyone.
And just to give you
some demos, these
are some of the datasets
that we have loaded
on the Public Datasets
Program and that we
are keeping updated.
For example, let me jump
to the New York City taxis.
Anyone knows how
many taxi rides there
are in New York every
month or every year?
Any guess?
AUDIENCE: 6 million?
FELIPE HOFFA: 6 million taxi
rides in New York every month?
More.
Yes, way more.
I know the number
for every year,
but I need to divide it by 12.
So I have this all loaded in
BigQuery, I'm sharing it here.
New York public data, taxi
trips from 2009 to 2016.
I know where to find
this, but normally people
don't know how to come here.
So if I was looking for taxi
dataset on BigQuery, we are now
offering a page
with documentation,
with the talks about
what's this dataset,
how frequently do we update it.
We have sample queries.
For example, let's look
at the average speed
of yellow taxi trips in 2015.
First, let me answer
the other question.
This table for 2015
has many columns.
And if we look at
the details, in 2015,
New York City saw 146
million taxi rides.
That's a pretty big number.
It's bigger than 8.
If we multiply it by
12, it gets closer.
Yeah, you were close.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
So if we want to
write queries, we
can write simple queries like--
let me query this table,
select, count, start.
That's a simple
one, 145 million.
But then we're able to
share queries with BigQuery.
We're not only
sharing the dataset,
anyone can come
and tell you, hey,
this is an interesting
query that you can run,
that you can modify, that you
can go and explore further.
I have to escape the
name of this table.
In this case, for
example, we are
looking at the average
speed of taxis in New York
during last year per hour.
And I also had to
do some clean up.
There's no dataset
that is really clean.
So for data to make
sense, here I'm
applying a ratio that looks
that the fair amount divided
by the trip distance is in
some normal rate of values.
And that's how I can tell
these rows are valid.
They're approximately
90% of the rows.
But that allows me to get
results that make sense instead
of averaging meaningless data.
Here I can see the speed
of taxis at 5:00 AM,
they go at 20 miles
per hour approx.
But then at 8:00 AM, they go
down to 11 miles per hour.
And then that's pretty constant
for the rest of the day.
You don't get speed change.
And now we're able to see it.
But then if we wanted
to ask questions like,
what about if we do it by year?
And we look at every year
between 2009 and 2016.
We can come [INAUDIBLE]
to the query.
Instead of looking at one table,
I can look at every table.
Here I process it 37
gigabytes in four seconds.
And we can quickly
see the results.
The speed of taxi rides has
been going down from 2009, 17.5,
to 12.8 miles per hour in 2016.
So New York is getting slower.
If you were wondering how
many rows did we just query,
just to brag, let me make a
count start of how many rows
I looked into.
These are pretty
handy, just being
able to start all the tables.
This was 1.2 billion taxi rides
analyzed in almost no time.
That is cool.
Just to show you other
datasets, we also
have the New York
City bike trips.
People in New York are
biking from place to place.
I can run similar analyses.
If I find my table,
these are the bike rides.
I have them for
San Francisco, too.
But in New York,
here are my trips.
And I have around 33
million bike trips.
And I can also start
querying them and looking.
For example, let's
ask any question
I have with the trip duration.
For example, I could look at the
average trip duration per year.
Start time.
There we got trip duration.
I can group by one, group by
year, I'll group by the year.
And this didn't work as I wanted
because this is standard SQL
and for standard SQL, I do
extract year from start time.
If you've been using
BigQuery for a long while,
BigQuery has its
own SQL dialect.
That was pretty convenient,
but not standard.
And now we support standard
SQL, which is really cool.
So we can see here, for
the last four years,
that the average duration
of a bike trip in New York
is around more than 50 minutes.
And what's really
cool with BigQuery
is when we start
thinking about how
to combine datasets, how we
can take the billion taxi trip
rides, take all these million
bike trips, and think about,
are, for example, cars
faster than bikes?
Or are bikes faster than cars?
Any guess?
Cars should be faster.
Well, bikes might be
faster, because it's a city.
AUDIENCE: --miles an hour--
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly At
11 miles per hour, so--
just to prove it and to have
the real data proving this,
I wrote a query that
I will copy paste
because it's a long query.
So with this query I'm going to
look at the most popular bike
ride starting point, endpoint.
I wrote that one not
with standard SQL.
And what are the most popular
bike rides, starting point,
ending point.
I'm going to look at all
of the taxi trips that
started in similar positions
and look at it only between 7:00
AM and 9:00 PM because it's
unfair to compare it at 5:00 AM
when taxis are at its fastest.
So there's a lot of trips--
4,600 trips starting in
Pershing Square and 33rd Street.
And with a bike, it
took eight minutes.
With a taxi, it took 10.
And now I'm proving
with real data
that yes, these bikes are faster
than all of the average taxi
rides.
And just being able
to look at this,
combine it, run a join
between two huge data
sets in 11 seconds, and being
able to share this query.
You can take the query
that I just wrote
and start changing
its parameters to find
whatever you want to find.
Taxis are not faster
always, but I still
have to build that visualization
to share it with you.
We have other datasets,
not only from scenic life.
For GitHub we have
not only every event
that is happening
on GitHub, we also
have all the source code on
GitHub that's open source
that we've found.
We've also put it on BigQuery.
So that's unstructured
data, source code
is just big desk files that we
can also analyze with BigQuery.
And the test I ran recently
was tabs versus spaces.
Anyone has seen it?
Tabs or spaces?
Tabs?
OK.
Spaces?
Good.
Let me get you the right number.
Tabs versus spaces.
This is the post I published
but I want to run it live.
So first I extracted
all of the--
I looked at the top
400,000 GitHub repositories
and I selected the files
from the top 30 languages.
This took like 10 minutes
just to extract from process
1.6 terabytes of code.
So as we did
duplicate files, this
is more like 14
terabytes of code
that these files represent.
With this query, I'm
looking at the extension,
I will look by
extension, I will look
to see if the line starts
with a tab or a space,
if files have more
tabs or more spaces.
I'll count it depending if it
has more tabs or spaces, files
with at least 10 lines.
I set up my rules, I bring my
query here, and let's run it.
That was fast because
I had it cached.
But if you want to
see how long it took,
let's not use cache results.
When it runs, it will
take about 10 seconds.
But I have my results
here that I also
want to visualize
just to see who won.
It took 14 seconds
to do it again.
So I can easily save
it on a Google sheet.
There are a lot of
tools to visualize
but I will use Google Sheets.
And this is my fastest way to
get something into a chart.
Tabs versus spaces.
It doesn't look that good,
so let me do a little change.
Let me copy this here.
I want to reproduce how I
did this famous chart now.
I just want to make these
numbers negative, the tabs.
What did I do here?
Minus 1, multiply by this, I
can make it go negative, copy.
Now it's negative.
Let's draw a chart,
insert chart.
Horizontal is prettier.
Let me stack it.
And boom.
This is the famous chart I
created between comparing
tabs and spaces.
And it doesn't take much
time to go and do it
if you know what you want.
Exploring is all the fun part.
But you can see, in
case you were wondering,
that in most languages, starting
with Java on the top one,
most people are
doing the spaces.
In C it's around 50/50.
But in every language, spaces
is what's winning right now.
Except in Go.
If you write in Go, that's
where you can keep your tabs
and no one will take
them away from you.
How are we doing on time?
I have been working
with other datasets.
We also have a Stack Overflow.
We are able to look
at all the questions
that people have asked
on Stack Overflow, what
are the top languages?
What are the top tabs?
Hacker News, that's really cool.
And what we started doing
yesterday with Hacker News,
in case you had been
looking at this dataset,
now we are updating it daily.
So for including
yesterday, I can
look at all of 13 million
posts on Hacker News.
To give you a demo, let's
look, for example, the URLs.
Let's look at the top
domains that people
share on Hacker News.
Regex, match, my
domains from my URL.
I can do a regular
expression that will look
at how do we find a domain.
Everything that is not a slash
between slashes, [INAUDIBLE].
Count, start.
And group again.
Any guess what's the top
domains shared on Hacker News?
Do you read Hacker News?
So for the last six years--
true or false?
Extract where URL
is not as empty.
So the top domain here
is GitHub.com, Medium,
people are sharing a
lot of Medium posts
on Hacker News, a lot
of YouTube videos,
a lot of TechCrunch posts.
There is something
strange with my URL.
Sometimes Hacker News doesn't
include the [INAUDIBLE].
But yes, people share a lot of
GitHub URLs, Medium, YouTube,
TechCrunch, and New York Times.
But this is what
people are sharing,
not really what
people are looking.
So if we look at score having
at least 30 uploads on Hacker
News, now GitHub
is still on top.
But The New York
Times is really,
really appreciated by
Hacker News readers,
TechCrunch, Medium is
further down, Ars Technica,
if you can remember it.
We can start playing with this.
I really want to share these
results as soon as possible
because I wasn't able to
share a look up to yesterday
with this dataset until now.
Now we also have weather.
I will just show you
quickly this post
that Reto wrote on how do we
combine all of the New York
City taxi data with weather.
We have all of the one-way
weather that's shared by NOAA,
we have it in BigQuery so
you can start combining it
with your own datasets
and start looking at,
do people behave differently
when it's warm, when
it's raining, when it's cold?
Weather has a huge
impact on what's
happening with your own apps,
with your own businesses.
And just being able to run
queries like these and start--
that's the TLC one.
Here Reto shared this whole
post on looking at the effect
of weather on New York.
And you can just come here to
BigQuery, bring your queries,
and start analyzing them.
Let me continue.
Let's get past BigQuery.
Let's talk a little bit about
how do we process image data.
With Landsat we are sharing
more than 14 petabytes
of satellite images.
Being able to analyze them is
not easy either, classically.
But we're working to
make these things easier.
You might have seen Dataflow
and Datalab in a different talk.
If not, please go and--
they're really amazing.
I won't go in all
detail with this,
but I just want to show you
the challenge of looking,
for example, what
[INAUDIBLE] was doing here
is creating a monthly
vegetation index.
Let's see how vegetation
is growing or going down
in each country, place, area.
This is not an easy
problem in theory.
You have to look at thousands
of satellite images,
you have to find the
least cloudy one,
you have to compute the
normalized difference
between certain vines to
see how much green you
have in your pictures.
But [INAUDIBLE] could
write a pipeline
that looks into these images,
filters them, and finds
the least cloudy in three
lines of Dataflow code.
Of course, each of these
methods is more complex.
It does the operation needed.
But just to bring it to make
it run at scale, to being
able to analyze all of this
data in parallel, orchestrated
by a serverless
framework like Dataflow,
it just took three
lines of Python code.
You can see the rest
of the puzzle, how
he's taking these
images, analyzing them,
and just get the
results without having
to take care of much of this.
This is a screenshot of
Dataflow on how it just takes
these three lines of code and
makes them a workflow that's
run by Google Cloud or
other open source systems,
like Flink or Spark.
Because Google Cloud Dataflow
has now the Beam API SDK,
which is an Apache API, which
runs not only in Dataflow,
but in other systems too.
But there are some other talks
that will go deeper into that.
Who has worked with Pub/Sub?
Yes.
Pub/Sub is our solution
for distributing messages
in real time, as
our queue system.
With it, I'm able
to produce messages.
Let's say this example
is from an IoT talk.
If you have to distribute
messages from devices
and send it to many
subscribers, with Pub/Sub
you can do just that.
Data producers can send
messages to Pub/Sub,
Pub/Sub is always
ready to consume them,
there's nothing to configure.
Then you can have
as many subscribers
as you need getting each
of these messages in almost
real time, all managed
magically by Google.
And the good news
for us, while I'm
talking about Pub/Sub in this
talk, is because it also has--
you can also share your
Pub/Sub datasets publicly.
So if you need to publish
that in real time,
you can send it here,
you can set it as public,
and then anyone that needs to
ingest this out in real time,
can do it.
We saw an example on the
keynote this morning.
Let me show you
quickly that example.
I will come back to this.
I want to show you--
this is from the New York City
Code Lab that we are running.
So in this case, the problem
we wanted to solve here
is, what happens
if New York wanted
to publish all of their
taxi rides in real time?
They're not publishing them
right now for various reasons.
But if they wanted, how
would they be able to do so?
So we took all of the historical
New York City taxi data
and we started publishing
on a public Pub/Sub feed.
And then anyone with
Pub/Sub can subscribe.
Here we created a
web page to do so.
I can subscribe to any
of the public topics.
I have this simulated feed
of taxi rides in real time
and I can just start
fetching them as a consumer.
You start just visualizing them.
In this case, for this
example we are running--
this site is around the
4,000 messages per second.
I'm right now receiving
2,000 data points per second
and just displaying them.
The message here, the main
concept behind this demo
is being able to share
messages in real time at scale
without managing anything.
And you can go a step
further with Dataflow,
that we were just talking about.
With Dataflow you could take
those messages in real time
and create a processing
system capable of transforming
these elements, windowing
them, doing whatever operations
you have to do.
And then publish either
to another Pub/Sub feed,
publish to BigQuery,
publish to Files,
just making your open
datasets, your real time
datasets available for everyone.
I don't have many public
datasets to share right now
in real time in this program,
but I'm really looking forward
to work with whoever
is ready and has
been feeling this problem of
how to share data in real time.
I'm starting with GitHub.
So for example, how do we get
from GitHub, every event that
is happening in GitHub in real
time so you could subscribe?
And the [INAUDIBLE] project
is helping us there.
A couple more demos and
from the open source world
because people always
ask me, show me
that you can do this with
not only inside BigQuery,
with other open source software.
Who has worked with
Apache Zeppelin?
OK, good.
So with Google, you're
able to run Apache Zeppelin
inside Dataproc.
I launched my cluster
some minutes ago.
Let me see if I
can connect to it.
So basically I
launched a cluster--
yeah, it's there.
If you want to launch a
cluster, you say, hey, Dataproc,
create a cluster with
this initialization action
that will run Zeppelin.
And once it's up in a couple of
minutes, you can connect to it.
I just created an SSH tunnel.
Here is my Zeppelin Notebook.
And Zeppelin can now
connect to BigQuery.
I have my interpreters
here, BigQuery here.
I just need to tell it
this is my project ID
and with that I can
start creating notebooks.
I'm connected to
BigQuery, let me see.
Let's run a query that
we have already run.
For example, what are the
most popular biking stations?
I can copy paste here.
So when we document
this, we need to Escape.
These are the most
popular bike stations.
The most popular has
had 300,000 trips.
And we can just
interact and bring it
to different platforms.
Whatever is our favorite
platform to analyze data,
we are able to
connect BigQuery to.
The most popular.
It doesn't look
too cool this way.
Let me see what looks cooler.
But they all receive
a lot of trips.
What I'm doing wrong?
Oh, I'm looking at the
start station latitude.
I want to get the
number of trips.
Not the latitude.
So these are the most
popular biking stations.
And the last visualization
demo I have is Data Studio.
Who has worked with Data Studio?
Good.
We have some hands.
We just made Data
Studio globally
available for free everyone.
So if you were
wondering when it's
going to be available
in my country,
it was available only in 22.
Now it's available for everyone.
You can come to Data
Studio, create a dashboard.
If you don't know SQL, you
don't need to know SQL anymore.
And you can just, if you
have a BigQuery account,
you can connect to BigQuery.
Let me find public samples.
How about we do--
let's do names, just to show--
or let's look at the most
popular names in the USA.
The subject query table, I can
give it my building project.
And I can connect to
any table on BigQuery,
Data Studio will
find the columns,
and I can quickly come
and create, for example,
a bar chart of names, what
are the most popular names?
There have been more
males than females
on these datasets so far.
But instead of
looking at gender,
let's look at the
most popular names.
The most popular names are
James, John, Robert, Michael,
William, Mary, David, Richard.
OK.
But I could also run a
filter and look it by state.
So this filter will do states.
I can close this one.
Now I have an
interactive dashboard.
So for example, if I only
want to see California,
I'm getting my results only
for California, or only
for New York, or only for
Texas, et cetera, et cetera,
et cetera.
But I have the freedom to
quickly create dashboards.
I don't need to know any SQL, it
will just be able to create it.
Also, it has this beautiful
share button, where I can also
make this dashboard public.
So anyone can come and run it
and start analyzing this data.
Going back to the
presentation mode,
the tools we were talking
about here is BigQuery,
you can analyze terabytes of
data in seconds just using SQL
and you can share data, anyone
can access your dataset.
With Pub/Sub you
can share streams.
With Cloud Storage, that
I didn't review much,
but with Cloud Storage
you can share files.
And you have plenty of tools,
Dataflow, Dataproc, Datalab,
Data Studio, CloudML,
Spreadsheets.
These are tools that
Google provides to analyze
and visualize this data.
And you can also use a
lot of third party tools
that we'll happily connect.
[INAUDIBLE], she's my favorite
open source dashboard,
Exploratorium, there are
so many other third party
tools that connect to this.
The whole point is, how
do we empower new ideas?
Not only in the ability
to analyze data, also
in the machine learning world.
Having this data available
which will revolutionize things.
We keep adding datasets
to the program.
Anyone can share
their own datasets.
But these are the ones that
we are grooming, and taking
care of, and keeping
updated, and we
keep adding more datasets
If you want our help
or you're thinking
that there is a very interesting
dataset that will help you
to have here, please tell us.
Yes, I'll let you take
a picture of the email.
We really want to bring as much
useful data as we can here.
You can share that
picture with me later.
Just to run a
quick query here, I
was looking at the number of
rows we're sharing right now,
a count start off
all the datasets
I listed previously,
it's 26 million rows.
There's way more
that we can share
and there's way
more that is being
shared outside of the program.
If you want to share a dataset
that you have on BigQuery,
you can go and look at
the dataset, press share.
As you can share it with
anyone in particular,
you can share it with
all authenticated users,
and that basically
makes it public.
Now, no one will find it if you
don't tell them where it is.
So we also want to have a
place where we can tell people,
hey, my dataset is
here, it's documented,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So the world is using open data
in many, many, many fields.
There is more than 500 data
portals, as I was telling you.
Especially if you are
one of these portals,
we would love to help to make
your datasets more available.
Let people query
them, combine them.
We have the perfect
platform for that.
In closing, the two
things to remember
is that we have awesome tools
to share and analyze data
and the Public Datasets
Program is here to support you.
I wanted to [INAUDIBLE].
We have a lot more--
please clap [INAUDIBLE].
We have a lot more
commercial dataset coming,
not only on the open
data site, we're
also announcing a lot
of commercial partners.
We also offer this tool,
Dataprep, to help load data,
make the process a whole easier.
It's in closed Beta right now.
And there's many more
interesting presentations
that you could join, visualizing
big data after this one,
how to migrate your data
warehouse to Google,
how to use Bigtable, BigQuery,
and iChats for ingesting
and visualizing data at scale.
I'm really looking forward
to advanced BigQuery features
tomorrow.
Oh, yes!
Now you can.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]